i now want to go over some of the other
core exponent properties but they really
just fall out of what we already know
about exponents let's say i have two
numbers a
and b
and i'm going to raise it to i could do
it in the abstract i could raise it to
the c power to the c power but i'll do a
little bit more concrete let's raise it
to the
fourth power what is that going to be
equal to well that's going to be equal
to that's going to be equal to i could
write it like this let me copy and paste
this copy and paste that's going to be
equal to
a b
times a b
times
a b
but what does that equal to
well when you just multiply a bunch of
numbers like this it doesn't matter what
order you're going to multiply it in so
you could this right over here is going
to be equivalent to a times a times a
times a
times we have four b's as well that
we're multiplying together times b
times b times b times b and what does
that equal to
well this right over here is a to the
fourth power
a to the fourth power and this right
over here
is b
b
to the fourth power
b to the fourth power and so you see if
you take the product of two numbers and
you raise them to some exponent that's
equivalent to taking each of the numbers
to that exponent and then taking their
product and here i just used the example
with four but you could do this really
with any arbitrary you could do this
with actually any
actually any integer or actually any any
exponent you can actually this property
holds and you could satisfy yourself by
trying different values and using the
same logic right over here but this is a
general property that let me write it
this way
that if i have
a to the b
a to the b to the c power
that this is going to be equal to
a to the c
a to the c times
b to the c
times b
to the c
power and we'll use this throughout
actually mathematics when we try to
simplify things or rewrite an expression
in a different way
now let me introduce you another core
idea here and this is the idea of
raising something to some power and i'll
just use the example of three
and then raising that to some power
what could this be simplified as
well let's think about it this is the
same thing as a to the third
this is the same thing we copy and paste
that
as a to the third times a to the third
is a to the third
times a to the third and what is a to
the third times this is equal to a to
the third times a to the third and
that's going to be equal to
a to the three plus three power we have
the same base and we and so we would add
and they're being multiplied they're
being raised to these two exponents so
it's going to be the sum of the
exponents which of course is going to be
equal to a
a
to the that's a different color a it's
going to be a to the sixth power
a to the sixth power so what just
happened over here
well i had i had two i took two a to the
thirds and i multiplied them together so
i took these two threes and added them
together so this essentially right over
here this right over here you could view
this as 2 times 3
this right over here is 2 times
2 times 3 that's how we got the 6. when
i raised something to one exponent and
then raised it to another that's
equivalent to
raising the base to the product of those
two exponents i just did it with this
example right over here but i encourage
you try other numbers to see how this
works and i could do this i could do
this in general i could say
a
to the b power
and then let me copy and paste that
so copy and then i'm going to raise that
and i'm going to raise that to the c
power
i'm going to raise that to the c power
well what is that going to give me well
i'm essentially going to have to take c
of these so 1
3 i don't know how large of a number c
is so i'll just do dot dot dot so dot
dot dot i have c of these
right over here
so that's what so i have c of these so
there's c
of them right over there so what is that
going to be equal to well that is going
to be equal to
a to the
well for each of these c i'm going to
have a b that i'm going to add together
so let me write this so i'm going to
have a b
plus b
plus b plus dot dot dot plus b and now i
have
c of these b's so i have c b's right
over here or you could view this as a
this is equal to a
to the
c times b power
c
or a you could do a to the c b power so
very useful so if someone were to say
what is
what is 35
to the
third power and then that raised to the
to the seventh power well this is going
obviously going to be a huge number but
we can at least simplify the expression
this is going to be equal to
35 to the product of these two exponents
it's going to be 35 to the 3 times 7 or
35 to the 21 or to the 21st power